Today...
Today, I am finally going to play the most requested game of all time.
I am finally going to play...
...  the most requested game...
... of all time.
One of my...
...  personal favourite video game titles...
That jid not just shape who I am...
That did not just shape who I am, but what I believe in.
... but what I believe in.
I'm talking, of course...
About CLUB PENGUIN (penguin club is shit btw)
... penguin!
(dramatic music with strings and drums)
(screams) No!
No!
My favourite game of all...
... time.
Club Penguin game on desktop, mobile devices will shut down...
March 29.
(dramatic music with strings and drums)
This can't...
... be happening.
I refuse to accept this.
... to accept this.
Trump is president. (Felix, you're in UK)
Fine...
Club penguin shutting down.
I say...
... I say No!
It's time to stop.
Hillary Clinton was garbage.
Okay, I get it. Trump won.
Hillary was shit
But this?!
This...
... tell me one good reason...
... for this...
To happen
There's nothing!
You got nothing!
There must be something that can be done.
There must be one thing, that I can do...
...  to use my influence to stop this.
As some of you know, I am right now at Club Penguin's old office.
The server room out there, which is locked by the way, I can't enter it
That server room, I'm not joking, I know it seems like I'm joking.
That server room, is running the Club Penguin servers
I... I got amazing fucking internet here
It's the fucking best
I basically have the last life line of Club Penguin in my hands
and am not gonna let some stupid idea stop my favorite game of all time
And I'm not gonna let some stupid idea
Stop my favorite game of all time
Club Penguin will... live
club penguin will live
[Accurate Subtitles: I got tired, bye. suffer from the last subtitles.
Let's look at the stats-.
Lets look at the stat
Club Penguin got plenty of page visits
but we need more, I want all of y'all
to play Club Penguin!
Show them the power of the Bros!
Show them what we can do!
We need to protest against this. He will
not divide us!
Club Penguin will not divide us
He will not divide us. Club penguin will not
divide us, say it with me
Club Penguin will not divide us!
Club Penguin will not divide us. Not my president!
Haven't we suffered enough
It's time. It's time to make another account
Club Penguin is the number one virtual world
for kids
how can you take that away from people
how can you just chew it up and spit it out
My last character got blown up
Club Penguin's virtual world will be
closing march in 27.. 29th
then why are we still here,
Just to suffer?
Every night I can feel my Club Penguin
(METAL GEAR SOLID V music)
In my arm
In my fingers
(more METAL GEAR SOLID V music)
this is not enough
we will end this. For Club Penguin!
For Club Penguin.
(alternate universe 9 11)
*door opens*
I need to get into the server room
This is the server room
It's locked
but I have the key card
it works
It's the only room they locked
Come on Club Penguin
C'mon
If I can get in here, I can stop it. I can stop this
horrible thing and then it will all just be a dream
Do you know how to like... break into the... now?
they always use the card in movies
It's literally just that one thing!
So it's just that one lock there
To make it in here
Well, I think if you had a little
flathead screwdriver, you can jimmy it in
and push this thing open
* Pewdiepie = Usain bolt confirmed*
Where did he go?
Is this illegal?
Almost definitely. Should we not be filming this?
It's for the greatest good.
Oh!
Brad: He's done it!
Pewds: It was so easy! Oh mah gawd!
Oh my god!
Ohhhh.
*Pewds thanks the skies*
What's inside this door...
It's gonna change... the world.
Should I open?
Brad: Yea
Ohmagad
It's more beautiful than I ever imagined (Wow)
This is Club Penguin's heart, and
it's bleeding
Think there's a reason they ke-
Oh shit. *Dun* *laughs* Sorry
We've just been hacked, it could be worse than Snowden
facial recognition got a hit
Jesus Christ thats Jason Bourne
What are we doing.. I... *laugh* sorry
We're gonna go *laughs*
F-fuck
I don't want to get evicted, I really don't want to get evicted
*laughs* Fuck
(off screen) How are you gonna save Club Penguin now? *laughs*
How are you gonna save Club Penguin from JAIL? *laughs*
There must be another way Brad
You know when things get hard
there's no other... when there seems like
there's no way out and you lose hope
You pray *Holy Music*
I must pray to the protector of penguins
the one that seeks to protect the earth
What's the biggest threat to penguins
oh that's right climate change
I'm must pray
to Al Gore
we need you once again join us
Al Gore, save the Penguins save Club Penguin
protect this server when I go to jail *laughs*
so say we in Al Gore's name: Amen
*Blast*
*Dramatic Music* (ff7 Sephiroth theme)
No, not you
Ainsley: Hahamwhahaha
Ainsley, are you the reason Club Penguin is dying?
yes, it is me, I have infected the club penguin servers
Long I have awaited for this day
And now, finally, my dream has been realized
Club Penguin shall fall
How could you do this?
haha i used you pewdiepie you swedish javla helvette
I though you loved me!
How could I love that which is unlovable.
You were my puppet you stupid boy
You were my brother Ainsley
You were supposed to bring balance to the corporate...
*zap* *Groans*
Unlimited power
*Dramatic Music* *Electric sounds* *Felix groans*
*Laughs*
*Coughs* You may have killed me Ainsley, b-*coughs* but you will not get past Al Gore
He was meant to be president... all along
(and here... felix dies)
*Dramatic Music*